les vacances d'hiver ont déjà commencé
le soleil est bien là mais certains
habitants de la cité du tennis ont du
mal à sortir
toujours sous le choc après la fusillade
de la veille quand vous sentez
aujourd'hui complètement démuni de toute
façon il faut qu'on déménage là je ne
vis plus c'est devenu l'enfer quoi s'est
il n'ya pas longtemps donc le mois
dernier il y avait eu des arrêts d
arrestation suite à un gros trafic de
drogue et là il ya des jeunes qui ont
pris le relais donc c'est un jour ça
finira mal
cette fusillade n'est pas la première
dans cette cité du creusot en effet la
violence liée au trafic de drogue s'est
installé depuis près de deux ans et le
sentiment d'insécurité grandes toitures
sur nos enfants maintenance et c'est ça
le problème
et ça fait des années que ça dure souci
là et personne ne fait rien ce soit les
élus la police et on arrive et on va en
arriver à faire justice nous mêmes c'est
grave c'est grave
alors je viens d'aller au commissariat
je reviens prévenu venait on est avec
vous il n'y a pas de souci tant que vous
êtes là pour calmer l'histoire on est là
là pas de problème on vous soutient mais
venez sont à présent regarder le jour
d'aujourd'hui satire hier aujourd'hui
encore personne n'a pas de policiers
alain du tout premier visé par les
critiques le maire du creusot se défend
il explique qu'un travail pour éradiquer
le trafic de drogue est mise en place
depuis plusieurs mois il ya des
policiers peut-être ne sont pas visibles
ça c'est possible mais je peux vous dire
qu'il ya eu des policiers dans ce
quartier là depuis plusieurs mois pas
forcément visible ce qui a permis
justement l'arrestation de pas mal de
personnes
ensuite il faut boire avec la police je
rappelle que la sécurité publique est
une prérogative régalienne de l'état
ce soir une demi compagnie de crs a été
envoyée sur place pour sécuriser le
quartier
une enquête est toujours en cours pour
tenter d'interpeller le ou les auteurs
de la fusillade